from the man who created some of your
fondest childhood memories then took a
huge dump on him comes the prequel
sequel that proved Phantom Menace wasn't
an accident this isn't how it's awfully
Star Wars Episode two attack of the
clones
once again the Republic is in turmoil
watch as the chin stroking Jedi are
pulled into a war between a completely
disposable droid army and a completely
disposable clone army seriously there's
no reason to get emotionally involved in
any of this crap experience an awkward
forced love story as soulless as the
computer it was made in with so many
visual effects the filmmakers didn't
have any time left over for things like
realistic choreography realistic
dialogue I'm haunted by the kiss that
you should never have given me or
realistic hated Christensen acting I
don't like sand its coarse rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere
not like him come on JJ there is no way
you can do any worse than this Natalie
Portman and her space hair returned as
senator Padme Amidala went to the
galaxy's best sharpshooting assassins
tried to kill her with a poisonous worm
pooping robot two Jedi Warriors will
come to her aid obi-wan Kenobi a man
forced to act opposite lifeless cgi
characters like Hayden Christensen and
Anakin Skywalker a rat tail atoll who's
been creepily stalking Padme for the
last decade I've thought about her every
day since we've parted I don't think she
liked me watching but much rather dream
about Padme you're exactly the Larry Moe
beyond my dreams please don't look at me
like that uh-huh
it makes me feel uncomfortable
sigh Malay good right along with these
one-dimensional heroes and a movie so
unevenly paced you'll have to wait over
an hour before you even meet the main
villain instead strap yourself in for
even more the stuff that made phantomon
is so cold lifeless and boring like
people sitting and talking standing and
talking walking and talking one person
standing and talking while another is
sitting and talking people standing and
talking then taking a seat for more
talking and a whole bunch of wipes
starring hey don't act again you in a
bad movie
yogurt m.bison nipply Portman Laurence
Fishburne definitely not the Emperor
[ __ ]
lulu darth Saruman and Jango unbraid
star wars episode 11 attack of the
clones so correct me if I'm wrong here
but the clones never actually attack
anyone in this movie so why the would
you call this movie attack of the clones
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
now this is podracing strike first
strike hard no mercy you never pick my
comments waffle falafel do you even lift
that's number way